I can get your hand off I'm sorry I hear
a lot of personal space issues in this
office today so this is this is teeth
yeah and I'm gonna walk around as best i
can it's interesting because like I i
just realized how how dependent I am
with for sound in this game is okay fun
it's kind of loud out here yeah so let's
let's see what happens so right now so
this is back this is after the game has
been finished this is out in the city
you get to kind of wander around the
city as Garrett as you please to you can
either go back to older mission areas
and do missions or you could just catch
up on all the side missions that you
didn't do okay right now I have a side
mission that's activated you can see it
up there's is where I have to get to but
as you also see I've also kind of I had
some anger management issues yeah it is
those fool leaving corpses strewn across
history beef way no it's not aren't you
supposed to drag him into the darkness
well you can I mean if you want to do
that I'll forget Utley left wave them no
no I'm all right I mean if you it you're
right it is important to dispose of
bodies properly that is a mechanic that
was in the original teeth you can how
much original teeth is in this new
terrorist some original teeth but
there's more there's some unoriginal
teeth as well that's not quite really
what what i meant i suppose there's
there's a little say assassin's creed
going on in here so let's zip up in
first person oh hey what we're doing is
still in first person while we do this i
just want to remind of folks are going
to have any questions for kevin about
teeth here on the xbox one too please
put them in the comments on the game saw
page or in the twitch chat or tweet out
gamespot as well but as you see that's
that's a little bit of a dead end you
know you see that that's where i need to
get to but sometimes the most obvious
way is not the appropriate way can just
a link up there that's a different game
okay fair enough so the good news is
that there are other there are other
ways of getting around sometimes you can
do things like activate focus to get an
idea of what it is that you're missing
now if I hadn't already fired that
ropero I would see by activating focus
up there you see that's an attached
point yep so unlike earlier thief games
where you can basically just an attached
an arrow at any block of wood that will
let you you have to do that in specific
areas here so
I can do that by that like the rope
arrow and then you fire it and so on and
so forth for now I'm just going to go up
at you gave this video game a a 60 out
of 10 and this this game kind of a lot
of people were anticipating it hard to
make a sequel to teeth even though it's
hot it's all in fair share of weird
sequels already and in what ways that
this kind of disappointing you well a
lot of it has to do with the way the
city is set up so the city is your hub
world here and this is how you get from
one mission to another but you also have
open world things to accomplish but it's
very very segmented it doesn't really
feel like a world as much as I said in
the review it feels more like a series
of connected walk-in closets right so it
feels like a world there there's some
other things to the way focus I'm not
necessarily against the idea of focus
even though real poor thief fans it's
the kind of thing that gets them all all
kind of pissy about it yeah but i'm not
against the way it was done i'm just you
know sort of against the the way it
makes the game easier without making me
feel more powerful at the same time so
do you preferred like you can play with
it turned off you can play with it turn
on i think usable or is oh yes it's
absolutely feasible cool what I found
though is that I did like the the focus
for one thing because focus isn't just
for seeing things like this sometimes it
can help you pick locks faster it helps
you beat up guards faster but I
eventually I did sort of enjoy having
the option to see what it was that I
might miss right but there are visual
cues even without it so is this not
level based in the same way that the
original teeth was I'm teeth to the
metal age or it is level based but you
use the you use the city as your hub
world to get from one place to look a so
it's it's you know you've sort of got
that in between gameplay to get you from
one place to another I've got a question
here from see silver wind on twitter
asks how is the quality of the sneaking
and teeth are the shadow mechanics
decent or are they kind of silly the
shadow mechanics this controller is
dying all right no okay button one more
time we will get will get a little life
out of it like all kind of a lot some
batteries for you here while you play
yes the shadow McCown the shadow is fine
I'm it works pretty well all things can
sidered there are some things that I
like that they did add however that our
new one of which is the swoop okay and
the swoop is basically a rush forward
mechanic and so it lets you do a little
sweet stache yeah as it were and that's
not something that you can turn off the
suit you cannot use it if you prefer not
to use it right but swooping is always
something that is turned on do you find
yourself getting involved in combat more
often mother well it depends on whether
I'm good right or not sometimes I'm not
good and I typically what I want to do
is not get involved in combat and
instead I'll I'll run ya if you run away
heads of the guards react because I
remember in the old games they would
search for you for a sort of short
enough period of time and and set back
to their yeah they they do some
searching as they should looks like
maybe this is a good bit the batteries
I'm gonna ask a couple of questions that
come in here thanks Chris I have a
friend who's the friend of the show
Eminem stranger one asks how is this
compared to dishonored it's a pretty
good comparison to make I guys well it's
a reasonable comparison considering that
dishonored was you know the thief
franchise inspired he dishonored as it
were but i would say that in terms of
any individual aspect dishonored is the
superior game in almost every regard
really so it's it's a game so good
dishonored is really really good in that
sense it's really hard for this game to
to really live up to oh we're having
lots of fun here no I've got more
questions friends of the show again mr.
carl duran sit 419 asks anyconnect voice
commands there are but i've not used
them yeah so I don't actually I can't
explain how they work there's something
connect related but that's not really
what I want out of my beef did you play
this on the PC as well i did play pc ps4
and xbox one is there any fundamental
difference between a pc in the console
versions well the pete there are some
differences the ps4 version has some
interface differences if you decide to
use the tickle tickle the controller way
of doing things chris is having fun over
there so that's you know that's there
you can but you can tailor
interface in various ways on all the
platforms the biggest difference
probably is of course pc versions are
typically more pretty yet that's that's
not really a surprise but the frame rate
can be a problem on consoles okay so and
when I say consoles I mean the next gen
consoles because I have not actually
played the 360 / ps3 version to ski ok
so but i but i will say i'm sort of
fascinated by the the frame rate issues
all things considered yes it's not open
per se you look at this and you see sort
of this area you think wow this looks
like a big see if our world or yeah well
you can see the frame rates yeah a
problem will slow down yeah oh but
here's the swoop swoop do i do that
every time I oh my God he's actually
hard as you worked so hard I I
disconnected so hard the crime Kevin so
although soup so hard University we're
having some connectivity issues with
this one it is what happens when it's
just 900p that's the consequence shots
fired consequence fight I want to ask
you this because we've talked about some
of the drawbacks we talked about some of
the some of the things that are a little
problematic and some things that are you
know don't compare favorably to other
games but a six on gamespot isn't a bad
it's not a bad score you know it's like
we've got some things that are caveats
but also you know there's a lot of good
reasons to play this game yeah this is
what are some of those this is one of
those interesting occasions where the
highs can be really high and the lows
can be what the f is this what are you
doing and but the highs can be really
high like there are these moments where
you you sneak in and you have to try to
make your way around these people and if
you're if you're doing it sneaky which
is the way you're supposed to do it if
you're if you're you know alerting
people you're doing something wrong I'm
you can get out of it but that these
great moments wow people are just
dropping controllers on me left and
right right so but the sum of the
neatest things are like when you can
sneak up and I wish I had a chance to
show you that and then the controller so
a game wonky but but i'll go into this
missionary and see if I can figure
something out it will ask me if I want
to replay a mission and i'll say yes and
we'll see what happens I've got a couple
of extra questions here as well a bunch
of combing through the game spot at shot
thank you very much but this one's from
Twitter on kid underscore you may is
asking so what's the overall plot of
this game
why you stealing but that's I'm a fan of
garish I'm a fan of why you will wear it
cuz he had well the old version had that
awful raspy voice on the intro and he
was just kind of a bad dude like he just
stole like there was a kind of a Robin
Hood thing going on there but it was
really it was just no yeah there's no
altruism here right he doesn't know
altruism to see he steals too he steals
from the rich and the poor and the end
everybody to give to himself that's
that's that's the thieving part of it
but there is there is a plot it's uh
it's of course set into play by a damsel
in distress oh here we go if yeah it's
it's not the most original thing does
garrett have a damsel that he liked
cares about he has a protege her name is
erin and in the very first in the very
first parts of the game you discover so
she's a little bit more wrong oh you're
getting the yellow I aggressively it can
I speak their peak right into their
crotches as they approach oh this is
what happens but rocket run alright so
you've got what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna see if I have time to do up a
blast air oh oh oh oh wow right in your
face let's face it like sitting on oh
God whatever I rock it in the wrong
place you are dead so sorry Gigi
yourself I did basically RPG myself in
this game is great oh shut up nicely
quite good but so Aaron the whole the
whole thing with the story is that you
watch Aaron sort of fall prey you you
stumble upon this mystical cults
situation and she falls into dumb magic
and lost love again is that a techno
club in the tank damn magic but it is
now alright so that's that's sort of the
thing the thing there is that that she
drives the plot and the in the meanwhile
there are some real issues considering
there's this up so the Barons in charge
of the city mmm right but there's a
there's sort of a populist named Orion's
out of water are oh that is a water
arrow I'm gonna be a little sneaky and
make sure that but that was my last
water arrow he loves them water arrows
you can oops wrong button you can turn
on the map if you prefer to have the map
bon thief enthusiast oh that's just with
a bug yeah yeah just a d-pad you can
turn that on I'm actually just so happy
to water hours in this again it's the
dumbest arrow in the world how does it
make any sense how do people not notice
a little water believable you notice if
I would have if I would have blown out
that fire there yeah um then they would
have noticed and they would have been
like huh what's going on somebody's not
a wheeler they will rely oh god what's
happening all right I'm gonna accept
this time I think we're having fun
attack should even it then culture guys
I've done magic is a problem I've got
one more question last one before we
wrap this up apologies all that
technical stuff that's that's on our end
that ain't the video is live hey vedder
fall near 1280 nine that's the guy who
took that username I wanted that excuse
me XXX no fun for tech 420 yeah he asks
about how long is the campaign with you
I think if you were to just so i spent
about 15 hours with the game and that
was just playing like I would normally
play I play the campaign play some side
missions I think if you were to just go
through the campaign and not pay any
attention to anything else probably
eight hours wants to do that don't you
want to get into the side missions are
they entice assignment into parowan so
that the story missions are much more
interesting as a rule because they give
you chances to sort of navigate into
thieving areas in different ways but
there are a lot of the side missions are
just go through a window look around and
press all of the buttons and steal all
of the things until you're done and
you've done everything that there is to
do but there are some really clever ones
one of my favorites is this thing where
you follow a drunk dude and you have to
sort of open doors for him and like find
ways for him to get around obstacles so
he can open a door for you to sneak
through that's for you that's pretty
clever especially because there's a
there's a prostitute there I don't think
this is this place is right this sounds
like there's a Friday night there's yeah
totally I en you know the neighborhood I
live in in sanford yeah all about this
so there's a there's a prostitute Dannel
sort of on this trapdoor and one of the
things you have to do is sort of is is
he gets stuck talking to her yeah and
one of you you like basically open this
trapdoor underneath her and she falls
into the river beanie
oh and then she's just down there the
whole time you come out and she's still
like hello and it's it's super funny
like one of those like knee deep in
river muck and that's one of the great
wants another another my other favorite
moment in the game isn't a story is a
story mission where there's this this
conversation between guards who are
stealing stuff off of corpses and
they're talking about whether they
should check the guys junks if they in
case they have [ __ ] work hahaha Oh
team a game of highs and lows yeah it's
a game of highs and lows just a game of
junk and oh brilliance and drowning
prostitutes in medieval rivers of poo
Kevin Bernard thank you very much at
teeth review teeth danky kang god were
all four people at the TT preview is on
gamespot com if you want to check out
the full version of that